uh morning all as boris johnson prepares
to set out his roadmap for easing
coronavirus restrictions next week
new data suggests the lockdown is
helping to cut infection rates in
england
but also this morning there is a warning
the nightclub's bars
and music venues could face extinction
unless
urgent action is taken np say more than
a thirds of workers in the nighttime
economy
have lost their jobs since the start of
the pandemic
now let's take you through a few of the
the key points of the day one of the
largest coronavirus surveys is found
that infections are falling in england
suggesting that lockdown
is working imperial college london's
react survey
found that cases are now at a similar
level to where they were
in september meanwhile sky news has seen
internal
whitehall documents indicating that on
reopening of the economy
in the weeks after pupils returned to
classrooms on the 8th of march with
hospitality venues potentially opening
up by the end of april
still all this as a cross-party group of
mps warns
that nightclubs bars music venues they
all face
being wiped out unless urgent action is
taken
this guy's emmy birchley has our first
report
for most of the past year this music
venue in east london has remained empty
when it would usually look like this
but with kovid thriving in crowded
spaces opening up hasn't been an option
it's left the owner of the oval space
wondering how his industry can survive
you need to be cautious but not super
cautious because if you're super
cautious you'll kill us
we've been shut for a year now if we're
not open sometime in the summer
we have to go into the autumn then a lot
of businesses i think will fail
now a report by a cross party group of
more than 40 mps
has echoed that warning predicting the
nighttime economy faces extinction
without urgent government action we need
some more support some grants
and some business rates relief extension
and a furler extension
and the things are going to keep these
venues going until they're able to open
fully but we also need a clear roadmap
for when they're going to be
open fully the report reveals that
nightclubs bars pubs and music venues
plus their suppliers have made more than
a third of their workforce redundant
in clubs alone the figure is over 50
percent
earlier this week the prime minister
described nightclubs and theaters
as the toughest nuts to crack when it
comes to finding a route to reopening
he dismissed the idea of vaccine
passports but suggested that rapid
testing
might provide a solution this time last
year jeremy joseph's nightclub heaven
was hosting the pussycat dolls with
crowds this big
he can't see how such testing could work
but he says
something needs to be done to be honest
when you talk about financial support
from the government
it's not really worth talking about i
mean we're not getting the monies that
we need for example
rent for our four venues comes to four
hundred and nine thousand pounds a
quarter
so the government gives you three
thousand a month that ain't going to
touch the sides
the government says clubs can continue
to access a package of support worth
over 280 billion pounds
and a plan for how businesses can reopen
will be outlined on monday
but with income from the uk's night life
estimated to contribute
66 billion to the uk economy there's an
awful lot at stake
emma birchley sky news
[Applause]
i'm pleased to say we're joined once
again on the programme by the care
minister helen waitley as well good to
have you on as always
and of course loads to talk about on on
your brief specifically but before we do
i i think we just need to reflect that
which we were hearing about the
hospitality sector
businesses in the night time economy
have an average made you know almost
40 percent of their staff redundant what
what support is going to be available to
the nighttime sector
when the economy does eventually reopen
i mean
it's clearly absolutely true to say that
uh hospitality sector
nighttime sector has been so hard hit
by the pandemic and by the restrictions
i mean
what we know is already there's been a
package of 280 billion pounds worth of
support
to the economy from the chancellor from
the government
and as of next week on monday the prime
minister's going to be setting out
the plan for how we come out of lockdown
and so to me that's a really important
thing
for us to be a step by step step and
doing this cautiously
of course because we want this to be the
last ever national lockdown
but step by step for us to be taking
forward um
coming coming out of these restrictions
firstly getting
children back to school but in due
course opening up hospitality
and getting back to life more like
normal i i suppose part of the problem
has been of course the government having
finite resources and determining where
they were to go you know before the
vaccine rollout started it was very
difficult to see
how the nighttime economies could get
back to anything approaching
normality i mean you appeared on the
show back at the tail end of september
you know said the following
it doesn't make sense to continue
supporting jobs where
there simply isn't work at the moment
was that though perhaps an oversight
given the fact that we have seen almost
four in ten workers in that sector
losing their jobs
well as i said i think you know the
important thing
is that in the weeks and months ahead we
take the steps to come
out of lockdown to move on from the
restrictions that we've had to have
over the the last you know months most
of the last
year and we've we're in a much much
better place now we've had nearly 16
million people
vaccinated that's a huge deal we have an
enormous testing capacity
as well and we've learned a huge amount
about the virus we've got better
treatments for it as well
um so i see us being in a much better
place as we come through this but we
will of course hear more from the prime
minister on monday
yeah a huge deal and indeed a huge
achievement of course um and
the roots out of all of this though is
of course where the focus is and
specifics will come on monday but
i understand that but as you said we all
want this to be the last
national lockdown the signal from
central government has been that we want
to be
relaxing things on a national basis
some suggest you know in the papers this
morning that that if there were to be an
outbreak we could see a return to
localized
lockdown conditions what's your view in
that
well i'd say probably wait until next
week until
uh when the prime minister sets out that
roadmap for how we're going to come
through it um but we have clearly
learned a huge amount we learned during
the summer about how to
manage localized outbreaks and take that
approach um but i
i don't really want to preempt what
we're going to hear next week
sure i thought i thought that might well
be the response um well let's let's talk
about schools are we of course
uh march the big date from for many many
people
not least not least the parents and all
of this and again we know that testing
in schools is going to be
is going to be part of the way we move
out of all of this but we're now being
told that
we could be seeing teachers and
secondary schools administering
one set of tests and then the
responsibility being put on to the
parents at least for
for secondary school students well first
let me say i mean
i like like many uh thousands of parents
i'm really looking forward to when
schools go back i've got three children
at home home
schooling and i think as all of us know
who are doing that
it's not the easy things thing to do and
gives you even more respect than you
already had for the teachers who usually
teach your children in fact have been
doing an amazing job providing online
support during the pandemic um so you
know we're looking forward
the plan is to for schools to be able to
start going back
on the 8th of march um and again next
week more will be set out about how the
return to school is going to work
i i i understand that but one thing we
can say with certainty is you know from
that react study that's out at the
moment
clearly some of the greatest
transmission that is taking place or the
highest amount of transmission that's
taking place is
is taking place in children it is taking
place in younger people
now that may well be a result of the
fact that they're not in school that
they're associating at home
but does that not give any pause for
concern does that not give any pause
ahead of the decision to reopen schools
on march 8th
well i mean what's been clear is that we
will look at the data
and the reason why we have put off
saying what the road map's going to be
until next week was to make sure that we
had time
to look at the data to to know that we
have vaccinated so many people to be
able to look at the impact
of the national lockdown on rates to
also
see how that has enabled hospitals to be
in a better position to cope
and there's one reason why a level of
caution is being counseled
to to recognize the lockdown is going to
we're going to come out of it step by
step
because we still have over 20 000 people
in hospital
we've covered we still had over a
thousand new admissions on saturday for
example
so no this isn't over yet though we have
this fantastic situation we're in of
nearly 16 million people
vaccinated the vaccination program going
at such a tremendous pace and there's a
brilliant job being done
by the nhs and by volunteers some of
them i've met
who are supporting the vaccine program
but we are going to have to take the
step by step but what we've always said
is we're determined to bring back
schools as quickly as we can
because we know that being out of school
is not the good thing for children's
education it's so much better for
children to be in school
and that's really important that we try
and get that to happen i mean
tell us a little bit minister about the
additional funding that's going to be
made available for
for looking at long covert i mean
clearly it is a condition of concern for
for all of us
but particularly of course for those
people who've been working on the front
line and have contracted covert through
you know doing their job and looking
after the rest of us
you're absolutely right and i mean what
we're seeing is about one in ten people
uh suffering from some form of long
covert so having
some symptoms that go on for three
months or more
quite a range of symptoms um but you
know some are
really making a a really tough to uh
live with and so we need to understand
more about this uh illness and how long
covered affects people and also how to
treat people and support people that's
one reason why today we're announcing
18 million pounds more going into
research
into long covid and exactly that how we
can help support people and treat people
and help people through it
i i'm part of the reason minister of
course that i mentioned those working on
the front line some
some really interesting data out today
about people applying to become
nurses nursing applications are in fact
up by a third you know i've got to say
slightly surprising to me that in the
middle of a viral pandemic you know
people are wanting to go out there and
help but
actually perhaps it's not desperately
surprising the british public
are running together well i think you
you put it exactly right there and i'm
really glad that you've brought this up
that um we're seeing from the ucas
figures out today that we've had a
third up uh third increase of
applications to study nursing
degrees um so we've had nearly 50 000
people
apply to study nursing already to start
this autumn
which is tremendous news for for me with
oversight of the nhs workforce it's a
really big deal because i want us to
make sure we have
more nurses that we have the workforce
that we need and we have 50 000
more nurses coming to the nhs by the end
of this parliament so
this is really important for the nhs but
exactly as you say it's a real
reflection
on how people have seen the fantastic
job that the nhs and actually social
care workers have done
throughout this pandemic and want to
step up and join them
and we've got that sense of public
service it's really really good news and
a real testament to
how our health and social care system
has been coping in this pandemic
yeah i mean of course another another
sector and one that you're directly
responsible for
that we need to see more people going
into is of course them the care
professions i mean
we learned yesterday and i know this
will be frustrating to you
but we learned yesterday that the social
care plan you know that boris johnson
promised back when he was
became prime minister in july 2019 has
again
somewhat been kicked into the long grass
no action being taken on that as i
understand it
until at least the end of the year can
you just provide some reassurance to
those
who have family members in care homes
who are perhaps working
in social care themselves that we are
actually going to start doing this at
some point because
you know the party has been in power
since 2010 and we have had a number of
promises on social care
everyone understands pandemics get in
the way of things
but it does feel like once again social
care is not where it should be
absolutely and i remember it was it was
roughly a year ago that the prime
minister asked me to take on the job of
being care minister
and then the job was very much going to
be driving forward our ambitions for
social care reform
then we've had the pandemic and
inevitably we've had to focus
all our resources and attention um on
on helping social care through this
really really difficult time
but we are absolutely determined that
we're going to take forward social care
reform there is work going on on this
we're going to come out with our
plan during the course of this year
we've seen
absolutely that the social care system
needs it it's been really tough for
social care to get through this pandemic
and so no i'm determined that coming
through this we will get to a better
place for social care
and make sure we get to a care system
that everybody knows is going to be
there for them and give them the care
that they need
and also as part of that make sure that
we really give the social care workforce
the recognition and the support that
they deserve for the really tough job
but actually really rewarding job that
they are doing too
well look people are are waiting for
that and they're eagerly waiting for
that and they have been they have been
eagerly waiting for for quite some time
um but just one last question on care
homes um
95 i think absolutely the end of the end
of january about 95
of care home residents had had their
first vaccine what is the earliest
possible moment
that people will be able to go and see
their relatives in care homes
i really really want to open up visiting
in care homes more i mean to be clear
we have made sure that visiting can
continue even during this national
lockdown
but i recognize it's not the normal kind
of visiting it's having to use screens
or visiting codes or
through windows if care homes don't have
those facilities i will say we have put
funding into social care to help care
homes have these facilities
and have extra staff if they need to
supervise
but what i want to do as we come out of
the national lockdown is
also increase the amount of visiting
i don't see that we have to wait for the
second vaccination
dose i want us to open up sooner than
that but i will say with this as with
generally as we come out of lockdown
we do have to be cautious um say
residents most residents in camps have
only had their first dose and some of
them
only very recently so it will be step by
step but i'm determined
so that we can see people you know go
back to to
know even if it's to be able to hold
hands again and to see somebody
who you haven't been able to see very
much in the last few months um
i know but last year i really want to
make that happen again
minister i know we've got to let you go
but just for clarity when you say second
dose do you mean second dose for
all of us or second those for care home
residents i meant for recurring
residents
great thank you minister great to have
you on the program thank you
thank you i want to speak to our
political correspondent kate mccann
uh listening to that interview what
let's talk to you actually just that
little bit of information that we had
from the minister at the end does
provide
you know some some indication that
actually
there could be more normalized visiting
within care homes relatively relatively
soon actually
yeah i totally agree with you i think at
the end there that could mean that
people could visit care homes within
weeks because remember most as you say
care home residents well they've all
been offered it most have taken it up
there are still some who
haven't been able to because of
outbreaks in actual care homes but if
helen whiteley is saying we don't need
to wait for second jabs actually
i think that things are safe as they are
then that could mean that families could
start to be able to see those people
that they've been separated from for so
long within weeks if the prime minister
lifts the lockdown restrictions we are
all living under of course because
some people won't be able to travel
beyond where they live if their
relatives are in a care home further
away so still we'll have to wait and see
what happens on monday
there were some sort of interesting
suggestions on social care that's such a
big issue the prime minister
made those pledges on it when he was
elected as you said and at the time that
was one of the most controversial
aspects of the election because
the promise was that people wouldn't
have to sell their homes for their care
now we know the economic situation is
vastly different to how it was then
it was already expensive it will be even
more so now
a little indication we'll see something
by the end of the year but what that
will be
i mean if it's another commission
another joint political commission that
will be disappointing for people
sorry kate many thanks indeed uh still
to come on the program this morning i'm
going to be discussing the future of
clubbing in the nighttime economy
with the dj fat tony he's going to be
here at five past
eight time for a different
vision secure stamina delivering his
thoughts on what should be in next
month's budget will be hearing
from the shadow chancellor just after
half past seven
and at 10 to 9 we're going to be joined
by a mum
of three who's been separated from her
husband for almost a year
because of coronavirus restrictions
uh to the united states now and as
authorities decide how to reopen schools
there
there is evidence that closures are
taking a toll on students well-being
they're seeing an increase in demand for
counselling sessions
as one expert warns of a growing mental
health crisis
our u.s correspondent greg miller has
the detail
well i often tell the story that uh when
i met a new acquaintance many years ago
and they asked about my family i said
dylan's going to have a
great life he's smart he's athletic he's
good looking
and he has lots of friends he'll be able
to do whatever he wants
it was barely a month ago that dylan
buckner took his own life
his family says school closures due to
the pandemic
played a part you know 450 000 people
and counting in the us have have died of
covid
and that's a terrible thing but i'm
fortunate
in that i don't know any of those people
but i do know one person who committed
suicide
there really is no doubt in my mind that
the lockdowns the
isolation the lack of in-person
schooling the lack of
in-person interaction with his friends
the lack of football
absolutely contributed to his death and
dylan's family isn't alone
across america the debate over whether
it's safe to reopen schools
now can't avoid what experts say is a
mental health crisis
a rising number of suicides in some
places
cries for help everywhere fewer than
half of students have returned to this
high school
in suburban chicago there is a quiet an
emptiness here
in these rooms there are virtual
counselling sessions
and the demand has increased for the
students that struggled
we started to see students that uh you
know
started to really show up with signs of
depression differently than they had
before
everything from not being able to take
care of themselves to
just not getting out of bed doing school
from their bed
and then not engaging in the class at
all
as schools everywhere work to reduce the
kovid risk
even a full return to class could come
too late for some
he was awesome and i know moms say that
about their kids
because every mom thinks their kid's
awesome but i'm not the only one that
thought he was awesome
being away from school changed trevor
till
i saw some of his light go out a little
bit um
it made him sad it made him angry you
know
he kind of felt lost
trevor took his own life in october his
family saw no warning signs
his mother says the isolation too much
for him
i think that the kids they need other
kids they need to be
involved they need to be in a classroom
with their teachers you know
you're missing all that interpersonal
stuff
that's very important i think there's
going to be a lot of ptsd from this
you know there is going to be a and as a
country we're not equipped
to handle you know mental problems or
mental
challenges at all it's really important
to talk to your kids
you know really talk to them but it's
also important too that friends talk to
friends i mean the reality of it is is
dylan
as much as we loved him and i think he
loved us and i think we were good
parents and had a very strong family
relationship
you know just couldn't open up to us uh
about his struggles in the same way he
could to his friends
i don't want anyone to have to go
through this
it is the worst it is the absolute worst
the reasons for any suicide of course
are complex and there are no easy
answers
but there are families who believe their
loss is just one more awful
hidden cost of this pandemic greg milam
sky news chicago
and if you're in any way concerned about
your mental health you can always email
the samaritans on
joejo samaritans.org or you can call the
number
on screen right now 116 123.
now the duke of edinburgh has spent a
second night in hospital as a
precautionary measure after feeling
unwell
prince philip will be spending a few
days in the private king edward at the
seventh hospital on the advice of
his doctors uh let's be disguised uh
lorna bunduck who's outside the hospital
in central london morning laura and i
think a lot of people will be
have been mightily reassured by that use
of the words precautionary
absolutely the duke has now spent his
second night here in hospital he was
brought here on tuesday evening by a car
said to have walked in and i think the
tone of the statement from buckingham
palace
was really significant explaining that
he was brought here on the advice of his
doctor for some rest for some
observation expected to be here for a
few
uh for a few days but it was the use of
those two words the fact that his
admission was a precautionary measure
it did seem to lessen the sense of alarm
about this also the fact that the queen
has stayed in windsor she's not in
london she was in windsor yesterday
carrying on with her royal duties it's
where the couple have spent
most of the pandemic we know they
received their covert vaccines there
last month also we don't really tend to
get many details about royal illnesses
but interestingly
this time we do know that the duke's
admission is not related to cove but it
is of course they're a worry he's 99
years old due to celebrate his 100th
birthday
later on this year but i think the
indications are good it wasn't an
emergency admission and he's said to be
in good spirits and that's how he seemed
last year of course we didn't see as
much of him these days since he
retired from public life but certainly
the outings the photos we've seen
he does seem to be in good spirits he
was last admitted to hospital back in
december 2019 he spent four days here
then and no doubt he'll be hoping this
time it's an equally short stay
and he'll be back home before too long
laura many thanks uh now let's have a
couple of the other stories making the
news this morning
facebook has announced it has blocked
users in australia from viewing and
sharing news on its platform
because of a proposed law in the country
the legislation would see digital giants
paying
news companies for their journalism the
restrictions now also mean that
international users outside australia
cannot see or share news from australian
outlets
on facebook
almost two million people were
unemployed or fully furloughed
in january and had been for at least six
months the resolution foundation has
suggested
keeping the job retention scheme in
place for several months in fact after
public health restrictions
are lifted
as we were discussing with the care
minister a record number of students
have applied to study nursing at
university during the pandemic according
to new ucas figures
there was a 34 increase in applications
to undergraduate nursing courses in
england
since last year
absolutely love this one after seven
months traveling through space
nasa's mars perseverance rover is to
make its final descent onto the red
planet later
and will begin to search for traces of
life
the mission backed by the uk government
is to collect samples
for future analysis from across mars
emergency services are investigating
after a house collapsed following a
suspected explosion in berry
homes had to be evacuated overnight and
power supplies were cut to dozens of
others
as molina vasilinovich reports
emergency services were called to this
street in berry last night
after an explosion tore through this
house in the middle of a terrace
residents nearby said they heard a huge
bang just before half past nine
there was just this huge noise it
sounded like
honestly like a bomb had been dropped in
the middle of the street i
expected to look out the window and just
like see a crater or something it was it
was unbelievable i've never heard
anything like it police told residents
to lock up their houses and evacuate to
a nearby garden center
northwest ambulance service said that
two people were taken to hospital
neither are thought to be seriously
injured this morning several homes
remain without electricity
as emergency services continue to
investigate the cause of the incident
milena vassalinerich sky news
let's return now to hanforth and
cheshire where parish councillors have
been meeting for the first time
since their well somewhat unruly zoom
bust up went
viral at this time around the public
were invited
but it appears calls for respect and
calm went
somewhat unheard i was trying
to be helpful george shut up
agreed yeah shut up george can i just
say
please let's respect each other
in texas thousands of sea turtles have
been rescued
after being stunned by the unusually
cold weather
the animals become somewhat lethargic in
cold water and have been washing up
on shore more than three and a half
thousand turtles in fact
been temporarily re-homed in a
convention center
but those plunging temperatures mean
volunteers are unsure
when the creatures will be able to
return to the ocean
time to see how the weather is looking
on this side of the atlantic joe
standing by how's it looking joe
it's looking rather unsettled it has to
be said uh fairly wet and windy for us
this week which makes a change from the
wintry conditions of course
but as we go into the weekend we've got
a big storm system coming in
it's already been named by the spanish
storm karim
it's going to give some very heavy rain
for them and no mean
rainfall totals for us either let's take
a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you yes it's all
rather unsettled at the moment here's
one area of rain making its way across
the country
and he is the next one that's making its
way in for the weekend and this one's
going to rather get stuck over western
parts
and get pulses of rain running along it
so that's where our
high rainfall totals are going to come
from this morning it's uh fairly chilly
across parts of ireland
uh mild across the uk mainland the rain
though pushing its way eastwards through
the course of the morning we'll see
the day's highest temperatures ahead of
that rain belt
so around 10 or 11 this morning we'll
see temperatures of 10 or 11
and then things cool down a little bit
through the afternoon as we see sunny
spells
and scattered showers starting to come
in cold again tonight early on
becoming milder later as this cloud rain
and strong winds work their way into
western parts
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
finally joe thank you uh still to come
on the program this morning we'll be
reporting from texas
where a huge winter storm has killed
more than 20 people
and left millions without electricity
[Music]
first and foremost i want to thank the
people that are adhering to
and the restrictions and
i think it's just been really hard
because i am a mum
and i do have a family at home and i do
have two children
who are homeschooling uh have an 18 year
old
who is waiting to get into university
who
isn't having the help that she requires
from
school in respect of there's no direct
help
i've got a 14 year old child who is at
home
and who who is doing really well on the
homeschooling
however it isn't at school and does have
his own anxieties about leaving the
house
and my husband works from home full-time
whilst trying to carry out his role as a
husband
working from home he's also continuing
to help with homeschooling
and i think from a working female's
point of view
as well as being a mum and i am coming
to work i have worked
all the way through covid and i am
expected
um to be out front facing
on the streets making sure that people
are safe and i think
it's about the anxieties around that
and the expectations that you to go out
there and do your job
which we do you know no problem uh
however you do take that anxiety home
[Music]
welcome back uh just a little more on
our top story now
and as boris johnson prepares to set out
his roadmap for easing coronavirus
restrictions next week
new data suggest that the lockdown is
helping to cut infection rates in
england
a little earlier i asked the care
minister helen waitley when people
could expect to be able to visit their
loved ones in care homes
in person she said visiting may be
opened up
before residents receive their second
vaccine doors
what i want to do as we come out of the
national lockdown is
also increase the amount of visiting
i don't see that we have to wait for the
second vaccination
dose i want us to open up sooner than
that but i will say with this as with
generally as we come out of lockdown
we do have to be cautious um say
residents most residents in canada only
had their first dose and some of them
only very recently so it will be step by
step
just for clarity when you say second
dose do you mean second dose
for all of us or second dose for care
home residents i meant for recurring
residents
now secure stammer is expected to accuse
the government
of offering only a road map to yesterday
in its post-pandemic response
in a speech broadcast online later today
the labour leader
is set to label the upcoming budget as a
well as a fork in the road uh the shadow
chancellor annalise dodge
uh john's is now on the program at ms
dodds always good to have you
on and let's talk about the budget and
of course
uh we're waiting to hear from us secure
just a little bit later on today
but it strikes me that what essentially
the labour party is saying is look there
are opportunities
uh being presented to us as we emerge uh
from this period of covert 19.
well there are opportunities that we
can't afford
not to seize because of the impact of
this period particularly on our economy
so the uk
has had the worst economic crisis of any
major economy during this crisis that
means we must do
all we can to particularly build the
jobs
of the future to give businesses more
confidence to ensure that our economy
does start growing again and kier will
be setting out later
a number of the ways that the chancellor
needs to be planning for the future
you know i would say unfortunately the
chancellor hasn't even taken the
decisions
he should have taken yesterday around
things like
continuing the business rates holiday
for example but he also as well as those
urgent decisions does need to be
planning for the future
especially around those additional jobs
that are so desperately needed
one of the more traditional dividing
lines between the conservative and labor
parties has obviously been
the amount of public sector spending i i
wonder if some of the attack lines from
the opposition side of the chamber on
budget they are are somewhat minimized
by the huge amounts of money that this
government has been spending
even on business well the big question
is whether those huge amounts
have been spent in order to protect jobs
and secure businesses for the future and
unfortunately
during this crisis we've seen
eye-watering amounts
of money being wasted and mismanaged and
we've urged government repeatedly to get
a grip on this
get a grip on those contracts that
aren't delivering
but also make sure that spending is
really targeted
you know when we've been calling for a
continuation of that holiday and
business rates
for companies that really need it we
said to the
conservative government please learn
from labour run wales for example
in wales they said that support should
be targeted at the smaller
companies so they didn't provide it to
the very biggest
essential retailers many of which have
actually seen their turnover increase
massively during this crisis so it's not
just about the amount
of money at all it really is about
whether it's directed
where it's needed whether it's
supporting jobs and businesses and it
has not been doing enough
in that regard over the last few months
should we talk about the nighttime
industries then just for a second
and of course i don't i don't know about
you but my clubbing days are largely
behind me but i'd still like the
opportunity
at some point to go out and enjoy a
night that doesn't end at
6 00 p.m i mean in terms of the night
time sectors
we have this all party group warning
today that they could be at risk of
extinction i mean the government really
has ignored the nighttime sectors up
until now
well i do think they have i should say i
do hope your clubbing days aren't
completely
over um i would say that actually you
know in the uk
and very often this is forgotten
actually
our performing arts our creative
industries
are an incredibly important part of our
economy very important for our
as well as domestically and they're
under incredible pressure now
and repeatedly we said to government
please again
look to the future consider the role of
these economies for the future
in our recovery we said to government
they need to be clear
now around those issues like business
rates but they
also need to be clear that for those
sectors
like the night time economy but there's
a number of other areas
as well where there will be pressure for
a number more months
government needs to be clear that there
will be that wage support
targeted and now delivering training
as well if they provided more certainty
then i think we would be in a different
situation
to where we are now where we've seen
record redundancies unfortunately
and where we're seeing many business
owners throwing in the towel
because they just cannot see that future
for their business that's bad for all of
us
not just bad for them sorry sorry to
interrupt we're just about out of time
but wasn't the government correct
to focus on parts of the economy that
that stood
any chance of opening i mean it was
pretty obvious from quite early on last
year
that you know people were not going to
be associating in live music venues were
not going to be going out clubbing
in the way in which they had done in
well i would say that we've actually had
a very stop-start approach to support
throughout this crisis i mean decisions
around
the continuation of the furlough scheme
for example last year were taken with
only five hours
left to go and that has been linked to
an increase
in unemployment in the uk at a time when
it was stabilizing
in other countries so really we've not
seen that application from government
across the board to provide
certainty around jobs for the future
that is what we need we need also to
have a vision
around the new jobs that we will need to
see for the uk
and that's why keira's calling for that
vision later on today in his speech
analyst good to have you on the show
this morning thanks for being with us
now texas you may have heard
experiencing some of its coldest
temperatures
in three decades in some parts of the
state
it has been as low as -18 degrees
celsius
and at least 21 deaths have been blamed
on the winter storm
high demand for electricity has also
caused the power grid to fail
more than four million people are
currently without
electricity our correspondent adam
parsons reports
for alex this must feel like the perfect
storm
heavy snow no water no electricity
and his wife due to give birth at any
moment i think she's
maybe instinctively kind of holding back
on having the baby just so
we can maybe have power and water and
roads can be a little bit clearer to
to get out but yeah definitely
definitely unnerving as we've gotten
closer to the due date he has stocked up
the habits of the past 12 months now
reaping a dividend
it's a lot kind of like what we've just
gone through with with the
pandemic um you know you're you're kind
of without services
you're without places to go so to a
certain extent we're a little used to it
supermarket shelves here are emptying
delivery lorries can't get through
people in this the richest country in
the world facing sudden
brutal hardship we're nervous because
people are starting to lose power again
you know right now i'm just worried
about does my son have enough food
you know i mean kind of
so i mean i've been trying to find stuff
but it's gotten hard
this state has little experience of
really arctic conditions and it is
struggling to cope
well this community has had a series of
power cuts which is why they've
hired their own generators to help them
cope they've also been without water
for a couple of days and even when it
comes back on
we've just seen a pipe bursting now it
is
hard to prepare for a once in a
generation event like this but there is
also
anger that more wasn't done to plan
ahead
and also that when they look at downtown
dallas
the banking headquarters and skyscrapers
simply don't seem to be affected
by the problems that they're having to
deal with here
it is that stark difference the feeling
that the rich elite are somehow
insulated from pain
that infuriates many obviously they're
going to have electricity down there
because of hospitals that's smart
you know we have to you know that's
where they need it the most i get that
but
you know those big companies and all
their big lights that's just
screams you know i don't give a crap is
what that screams
texas has had days to sort this out but
it is still in a state of chaos
there's warmer weather on the way and
for many it just can't come soon enough
adam parsons sky news avondale in texas
still to come on the programme at the
call for better investment
in youth services after new research
finds funding has been cut
by almost three quarters
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a walk that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed we take you to the
heart of stories
that shape our world they were convinced
the united states would become hooked
[Music]
we hear shotguns being fired and also
tear gas is being
put around the information on this could
bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria
but across the world
[Applause]
it's out of control but the fever drawn
it's oh so hot
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
[Applause]
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back
the ymca says the future of thousands of
anxious isolated and vulnerable young
people
would be at risk if more funding isn't
reinvested into youth services
across the uk this guy sadia cherdari
reports
it was a programme aimed at empowering
girls that turned macy from a teenager
with anxiety
to her new confident self the 17 year
old says she's an example of why youth
centers and their workers are so
important
even during the lockdown the ymca
and the british red cross have given me
so many opportunities
where it's took my mind off not being
able to concentrate at school or the
fact that
i didn't know what my gcses were going
to be or going starting into
my a levels the sort of help macy had
access to is on the decline
because many child services across the
country simply can't afford to stay
open the ymca says local authority
spending on youth services in england
fell last year by six per cent
it says that means funding for youth
services has been cut by 73 percent over
the last decade
if you think about a local community
that's had facilities and programs in
place for
young people to engage with and then
suddenly overnight they just disappear
where do young people go then they go on
the streets and we wonder why there are
problems with crime and disorder in
local communities
hello how are you doing in manchester
it's here on the streets
that vital youth work takes place
manchester young live ceo
is paul fletcher who says that without
the workers
a young person could get drawn into a
gang within a matter of days
they look to belong somewhere and that
alternative subculture
is is the dangerous place for them to go
to but unfortunately
too many of them gravitate towards all
those activities a government
spokesperson said
we recognize the vital role youth
services play and are providing
dedicated support to help them manage
the impact of the pandemic on young
people
we have provided more than 250 million
pounds of dedicated support for youth
organizations
building on the 11 billion pounds given
to local authorities this year
who have a statutory duty to allocate
funding to youth services
in line with local needs youth services
are calling on the government to help
change the course of the future for
thousands of anxious and isolated young
people
amid warnings that without adequate
reinvestment in youth services
we could be creating a lonely lost
generation with nowhere to turn
sadia chowdhury sky news in manchester
uh anywhere you look at it testing is
central to the way in which we will be
coming out of lockdown
be it mass testing for asymptomatic
carriers
whether it is testing in schools or
indeed whether it is test and trace
and there are some arguing that local
authorities
should now be administering that part of
our response let's speak now
to the chair of bolton nhs foundation
trust
professor donna hall professor hall
great to have you uh
on the program this morning um i wonder
if we might start with that
with test and trace and and clearly if
we are to to avoid
clusters turning into widespread
community infection
as we start to see lockdown restricting
it has to play a big part
i suppose the question is is it better
to be administered or local
or a national level
i think definitely at a local level
we've seen the different
impacts on communities of of coronavirus
and how it impacts differently in
more deprived communities it comes up in
little
spikes every now and again in workplaces
in schools
in local gp practices and around those
areas
but what we've got at the moment is two
parallel systems we've got a national
system
and a local system still not properly
speaking to each other so for example if
you're a teacher
in a school and you have symptoms you'll
go and get tested and it'll be the
national system
that that tests you and then deals with
all your contacts
if there's an outbreak in a local school
it's local authorities and local gp
practices that have to respond at a
local level
so you've got a completely crazy system
that just doesn't connect
around the individual and the family uh
you know a few months ago we we saw that
people were being contacted 20 30 times
a day in the same family
by the national contact testing system
it really does need to come down to a
local level have one
proper resource system we've seen the
beauty of the vaccine rollout that's
been done
at the local level you know using gp
practices the local nhs
using local authorities public health
teams and the army as well you know
really resourcing that and we've seen
how amazing that's been
by just having one system that works
properly at the local level
it's really confusing for people local
authorities are really in despair
you've seen the resource constraints in
the last item on youth services
where over the last 10 years local
authority budgets have been almost
halved
by in terms of funding cuts so we need
the resources
public health teams have been set up to
do this this is their job
and we're going to be living with this
virus for at least the next 18 months to
two years
so to continue to fund a 22 billion
pounds
private sector initiative is just not
sustainable
i mean the the key word there is is
resources though surely as things stand
at local authorities uh the local groups
that would be administering this
need an awful lot in terms of
infrastructure money and uh
and so on if they were to be able to
carry this out
absolutely but they've really stepped up
neil despite the resource constraints
that they have and this is what the nhs
does incredibly well with
local authority colleagues we just we
just get stuck in so 60
of contacts that have been traced have
been through the local system
so why not just give all the resources
the 22 billion that we've given to
private sector companies let's give it
to public services we've seen that they
can do it
let's believe in them and invest in them
and we'll make sure we get through this
virus
i mean professor just some news that has
reached us in the past couple of days of
course is the use of the the lateral
flow tests
some mass surge testing do you have any
concerns about that i mean
the the the false negatives that have
been reported
uh in terms of lateral flow are
certainly significant
yes we're finding that that um that lots
of the uh
false negatives that are coming forward
it's very very concerning
it's not about the numbers of tests and
this seems to be an obsession about
numbers of tests
it's actually about the effectiveness of
the tests the efficacy of
uh of the vaccine and how we're all
working together to stop these continued
outbreaks
as the virus mutates this is not going
to go away so we need to have a really
robust
very very connected integrated system at
the local level
and you know the lateral floor test is
just an example we
we found out the other day that some
asda stores within
the country are going to be getting
these tests not all of them but some of
them
but the local authority in that area
didn't know about it so
it's kind of two different bits of the
system that are not speaking to each
other
and you know we've seen that when there
are outbreaks in workplaces for example
the meat factories that you will have
that you did report on um it was local
government that got stuck in there that
closed down the factories
20 000 people a day and not
self-isolating that's where local
government comes in to support them
to help them to knock on the doors to
provide housing support
to provide welfare support food parcels
and to support them
through the self-isolation process it's
got to be an integrated system
and at the moment it isn't professor
donahoe chair of bolton nhs foundation
trust great to have you on this morning
thanks be with us
thanks neil thank you very much time for
us to see how the weather is looking joe
is at the wall
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you it's
looking a little bit wet over the next
few days but uh
as it's fairly mild it should be warm
rain at least which is uh some
consolation
however there will be quite a lot of it
this system coming in uh storm mccallum
is uh going to uh give some significant
rainfall over western parts of the
country perhaps 150 millimeters
uh which may lead to some localized
flooding we've got further rain today
it's currently over western parts it'll
be pushing its way eastwards through the
day and we'll see
sunshine and showers following on those
showers uh most concentrated up towards
the north and the west particularly over
western parts of scotland
it is going to be windy everywhere with
gales around western coasts and
temperatures at best
around 10 or 11 degrees celsius 52
fahrenheit
the weather sponsored by qatar airways